inciso d sea subíndice 4 el polinomio de
cuarto grado de la serie de taylor para
efe alrededor de x igual a 0 usa la
información de la gráfica de ye igual al
valor absoluto de la quinta derivada de
x que se muestra a continuación es la
gráfica que tengo ya aquí para mostrar
que el valor absoluto del polinomio de
cuarto grado de la serie de taylor
evaluado en un cuarto menos la función
evaluada en un cuarto es menor que 1
entre 3000 y este problema ya está mucho
más interesante que todos los demás
desde cuenta que ya puse la gráfica de
ye igual al valor absoluto de la de
quinta derivada de x porque ya la voy a
ocupar entonces qué es lo que me piden
me piden que el valor absoluto del
polinomio de cuarto grado evaluado en un
cuarto menos la función evaluada en un
cuarto todo esto un valor absoluto es
menor que 1 entre 3000 es decir el error
que tengo al comparar mi polinomio de
cuarto grado de la serie de taylor
mi aproximación de ese polinomio
comparado con mi función evaluado
en un cuarto entonces vamos a tratar de
hacer una gráfica supongamos que esta
era mi función
original y yo lo que tenía era una
aproximación alrededor del punto x0 que
es este de aquí entonces mi aproximación
supongamos que es esta función de
amarillo que tengo yo aquí se dan cuenta
en cero pues las funciones son iguales
pero yo lo que quiero ahorita es ver qué
margen de error estoy cometiendo no en
el cero sino en mi función evaluada en
un cuarto entonces este es el punto 14 y
dese cuenta que yo aquí tengo mi
polinomio me aproximación en un cuarto y
aquí yo tengo la función original y yo
lo que quiero es la distancia entre
ellas dos o dicho de otra manera el
error que yo estoy cometiendo con mi
aproximación de los cuatro primeros
términos de mi serie de taylor alrededor
de x igual a cero yo lo que quiero
mostrar es que ese error es más pequeño
que uno entre 3.000 y bueno para
resolver este problema hay algo que
ustedes deben saber algo donde yo
construir un vídeo creo que era un par
de vídeos en la sección de cálculo de la
página de khan academy punto org
en el cual yo trataba acerca de la idea
del límite o no recuerdo si era
aproximación la serie de taylor o error
algo así se llamaba en los vídeos pero
lo importante aquí era la esencia que
hay detrás de cómo vamos a resolver esto
si ésta es fx y yo agarro un polinomio
de grado n de x un polinomio de grado n
de x de la serie de taylor alrededor de
un punto y en este caso el punto hay es
x igual a 0 pero bueno el polinomio de
grado n de la serie de taylor está
alrededor de un punto x iguala a muy
bien yo lo que quiero enseñarles y lo
que vimos en este vídeo es como
construyó la función de error entonces
le voy a poner aquí error la función del
error del polinomio de grado en
alrededor del punto a que es a su vez
una función de x
el error estamos hablando de la
diferencia va a ser la diferencia entre
estas dos cosas que tengo aquí entre la
función de x menos el polinomio de grado
ndx de la serie de taylor entonces es fx
menos el polinomio de grado ndx y bueno
de hecho diosito me cuadra absoluto aquí
pues es lo mismo que tomar el valor
absoluto aquí y por lo tanto pues esto
es lo mismo que decir que el valor
absoluto del polinomio de grado n de x
menos la función fx y lo importante que
nosotros debemos saber es que este error
lo podemos acotar lo vamos a poder
acotar es que este error depende de n de
un valor n del grado del polinomio pero
si nosotros sabemos propiedades acerca
de la n-1 derivada entonces estas
propiedades nos van a ayudar si nosotros
sabemos
que la n-1 derivada de esta función de
fx es menor o igual que una cierto valor
m el otro absoluto el valor absoluto de
esta animación derivada de x es menor o
igual que un cierto valor m en un
intervalo como decirlo en x existente en
el intervalo cerrado a b donde b es un
número que es mayor que a eso es
importante donde b es más grande que am
entonces va a pasar lo siguiente y esto
lo vimos en el vídeo que les comento
acerca de los límites acerca de la del
error de aproximación en la serie de
taylor pasa lo siguiente
entonces el valor absoluto del error de
x va a ser menor y aquí está incluido el
error el error que queremos va a ser
menor o igual va a ser a valor absoluto
es menor o igual que que quien va a ser
a pues esa vez probamos que esto es
menor o igual que m por x menos elevado
a la n 1 entre en + 1 y aquí ya tenemos
una cuota para el error y bueno yo sé
que no es momento de demostrar este este
enunciado que le estoy diciendo si
quieren demostrarlo si quieren
recordarlo sería bueno que vean el vídeo
que le estaba comentando sin embargo qué
útil va a ser utilizar este enunciado
que estoy mencionando aquí y aunque no
lo pruebe porque este es un vídeo de las
respuestas del examen de cálculo bc de
2011 lo que si va a ser muy importante
es utilizar este esta frase que tengo yo
aquí entonces bueno nosotros sabemos
quién es el polinomio
4dx que aproximaba a la serie de los
nosotros habíamos sacado un delicioso
ave esta aproximación de cuatro términos
y si nosotros queremos el por el nombre
de grado cuatro pues son solamente uno
más x cuadradas sobre dos y a esto hay
que sumarle x cuarta sobre cuatro
factorial y entonces pues ya puedo yo
utilizar una cota o una aproximación
para este error de hecho esta cota ya es
muy sencilla porque ya lo que hay que
hacer es solamente sustituir en esta
cota para el error de x entonces pues
vamos a hacerlo el error del que
estábamos hablando en este teorema es el
error subíndice en el que es el error
que teníamos aquí arriba es el que error
que queremos entonces que me va a quedar
pues el valor absoluto del error 4
porque el que quiero es el polinomio de
grado 4 de xx no realmente quiero
evaluado en un cuarto entonces yo lo que
quiero es el error en un cuarto esto va
a ser en valor absoluto menor o igual a
quien bueno estamos de que sustituir
desde cuenta que aquí b es un cuarto y
pues es el valor que nosotros teníamos
de x
igual a cero entonces esto va a ser
menor o igual que m
m que tenemos que encontrar por b bueno
me vale un cuarto entonces una vez por
un cuarto menos pero a vale cero
entonces siempre y sencillamente un
cuarto se queda m por un cuarto elevado
a la enee más uno pero en es 4 entonces
solamente hay que poner en 1 es 5
entonces es un cuarto a la quinta
potencia y todo esto es dividido entre 5
expedientes verdad que hay un pequeño
error ese de massú no factoriales pero
no confundirlos es n 1 factorial
entonces es entre 5 factorial perdón es
por aquí el error de además no
factoriales pero no confundirlos pero
así dice el teorema que les estaba
mencionando entonces entre 5 factorial
pero aquí no acaba denunciado este error
se cumple si pasa lo siguiente si pasa
que
efe si pasa que la derivada quinta de
equis en valor absoluto es muy
importante menor absoluto es menor o
igual que una cuota m está en valor
absoluto es menor que una cuota m sí yo
sé esto en el intervalo en el que está x
x está en el intervalo de a a era cero
entonces el intervalo de cero a b que
era un cuarto
entonces si yo encuentro una cota en
este intervalo para el cual mi función
es siempre menor entonces yo sé que este
error si se puede aproximar y vamos a
ver si nosotros nos damos cuenta aquí es
un cuarto entonces si aquí es un cuarto
pues este valor es como 32 33 no sé pero
lo que sí estoy segurísimo es que es
menor que 40 en el intervalo 0 a un
cuarto
esta función de la derivada quinta de x
es menor que 40 entonces ya tenemos una
buena cuota para el m en lugar de vamos
a poner 40 sustituimos a m por 40 y
ahora sí voy a reescribir todo esto para
que quede mucho más limpio entonces voy
a bajarlo a algunas personas en lugar de
poner el error subíndice 4 de un cuarto
prefieren ponerlo ya como está que es el
valor absoluto del polinomio de grado 4
evaluado en un cuarto menos
evaluado en un cuarto recuerden que esto
lo habíamos definido así desde un
principio es evaluado en un cuarto en
valor absoluto es menor o igual a quien
pues bueno es menor o igual que 40 por
el cuarto a la quinta pero uno a la
quinta es uno y cuatro a la quinta pues
quien se dé cuenta de saber que vamos a
ver entonces esto es lo mismo que 40
entre 4 a la quinta por 5 factorial pero
simple factorial es lo mismo que 5 por 4
por 3 por 2 por 1 pero pues el 1 no lo
ponemos y bueno esto lo podemos reducir
porque pues que 40 le podemos sacar
cuarta y es 10 entonces le sacamos
cuarta y esto es 1 le podemos sacar
quinta que es 2 entonces es 1 le podemos
sacar mitad que es 1 mitad que es bueno
entonces aquí también tenemos echamos de
dos y ahora sí que nos quedamos queda
algo este más reducido entonces esto es
menor o igual donde propongo lo voy a
poner más abajo esto es menor o igual
que 1 entre 4 a la quinta por 3
a esto hay que multiplicarlo por el 3
que era lo único que me había sobrado
del 5 factorial por 3 bien pero bueno
cuántos 4 a la quinta 4 de quinta quién
sabe cuánto sea pero es lo mismo que 2 a
la décima entonces 4 a la quinta por las
leyes de los exponentes es lo mismo que
2 a la décima porque 4 estos al cuadrado
y bueno 2 a la décima es lo mismo que
1024 ustedes lo pueden hacer a mano o lo
pueden sacar una calculadora pero dos a
la décima es 1024 entonces esto es menor
o igual que uno entre 1024 por tres en
el 24 por 3 pues tres por mil es 3.000 y
24 por 33 72 entonces esto es menor o
igual que uno entre tres mil 72 muy bien
entonces ya tenemos que esta diferencia
que tenemos aquí en valor absoluto es
menor o igual que uno entre 3.000 72 que
nosotros queríamos que esta diferencia
fuera menor que uno entre 3.000 pero
pues ya acabamos por qué pues porque
claramente uno entre tres mil 72 es
menor o igual que 1
33 mil entre 3000 y un error 3000 que
era lo que yo quería probar que el error
en un cuarto era menor que 1 entre 3000
lo que la diferencia entre esos dos
valores era menor que 1 entre 3000